ap
c'est dans le cadre des nouvelles
installations d'orly que le général de
gaulle a accueilli le président de la
république gabonaise monsieur léon m'ba
second chef d'état de la communauté à
être l'hôte officielle de la france
après le président de sierra
la visite du président demain devait
durer trois jours trois jours marquée
par des entretiens au palais de l'elysée
et qui se sont achevés par une soirée de
gala à la comédie-française trois jours
aussi qu'ils auront fait écho aux
paroles que prononcer le président de ba
sont arrivés tout gabonais à deux
patries le gabon et la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce pari tout plein de secrets disait
léon paul fargue qui on connaissait
quelques-uns secret des judas secret des
mots de passe et nous voici dans un des
clubs les plus récents et les plus
fermés où se retrouvent quant aux gens
de lettres de théâtre et de cinéma
cette nuit pierre jean vaillard
coudoient jean-pier roulement et marisa
pavant
le dauphin et robert marchand imaginer
un sketch et dictent leur réplique
[Musique]
françois patrice et jean claude brialy
entourent michel morgo celle à minuit
des la sainte et studieuse du club
saint-hilaire musique
on dansera un peu ce soir tout de même
plus sucrés et moins fréquenté le club
des explorateurs sous l'oeil de
lapérouse chaque mois se réunissent des
gens que généralement on ne rencontre
pas à paris ils sont au mato grosso au
tibet en terre adélie haute année sauf à
chacun de leur passage ils se retrouvent
s'interroge se racontent un peu
gardinier vient de parcourir le yoga
monsieur et madame villaret arrive dcn
lyotard est allé au pôle sud jacquet
petty villeminot ont appris à lancer le
boomerang avec les papous d'australie
centrale est un peu plus loin bertrand
flornoy rêve des sources de l'amazone
sortant sur la pointe des pieds
tout secret toujours top secret même là
nous sommes dans un repaire de
flibustiers signe distinctif un vieux
doublons d'espagne les plaint des
châteaux en ruine les rébus laissés par
les capitaines davanture les testaments
devinettes écrit par des ancêtres
cachottier sont le thème de leurs
discussions
on tire des plans sur la bête de vigo et
l'île de la tortue un décor d'edgar poe
des personnages de mac orlan ne me
demandez rien de plus
ses secrets
[Musique]
à l'occasion de leur congrès qui se
tenait cette année à turin directeur et
les rédacteurs en chef des journaux
films et d'europe ont tenu à visiter les
travaux de la prochaine exposition
universelle qui marquera le centenaire
de l'unification italienne le futur
palais du travail d'inspiration
résolument moderne peut être considéré
dès maintenant comme l'une des
expressions les plus étonnantes de l'
architecture actuelle
le salon des peintres témoins de leur
temps tu es maintenant un classique de
l'année ce que c'est que dix ans
d'existence
aujourd'hui il a réuni sur le thème des
richesses de la france 100 exposants
autour de quelques grands aînés ou
légers gronert tiennent compagnie art ou
chagall et ses étranges sirènes d'un
saint germain des prés saturé de magie
regarde dans la salle un fujita naturel
en contemplation devant à nutri l'eau
[Musique]
mathis est là lui aussi et d'autres qui
compte parmi les richesses de la france
et c'est bien cela qu'a compris un
certain rené coty qui les connaît bien
[Musique]
rien de commun entre ce statisme
figuratif que certains disent désuet et
cette exposition d'un art en marche qui
s'est ouverte à amsterdam
cet art en marche est d'ailleurs
consacrée au mouvement et même
pourrait-on dire au mouvement perpétuel
réussite parfaite et 6e salon artistique
fait un peu penser aux marchés à la
ferraille et au congrès des petits
inventeur farfelu c'est qu'on a l'esprit
mal tourné
l'un de ses appareils pousse même le
génie jusqu'à peindre lui même
chef-d'oeuvre engendrant des shader
tout cela fait du bruit bouge très chaud
autre mutin 13 hommes
du grand art on vous dit et tellement
vrai
35 chevaux au départ du grand national
de liverpool 28 millions d'anciens
francs au vainqueur
mais pour gagner il faut franchir sans
encombre les 30 obstacles répartis sur
les 7000 mètres du parc où tu es la
première es c'est le début de la grande
débâcle encore quelques concurrents deux
mois après le second obstacle à la
troisième mais on commence à y voit un
tout petit peu plus clair
ce cheval manifestement plus doués pour
les courses de plat a préféré changer de
parcours sans égard pour son jacques
restera-t-il un cheval et un jockey pour
franchir ensemble la ligne d'arrivée
oui ils sont tout de même encore 14 au
dernier obstacle
colas les éleveurs se détache dans la
dernière ligne droite et remporte
facilement le grand national devant le
vainqueur de l'an dernier
lorsque débute le match france galles à
colombes
les joueurs manifestent leur intention
de ne pas se faire de cadeaux on est
comme ça tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet les français qui joue un maillot
blanc culotte noire attaque premier
exploit de bouquets numéro 12 crochet
intérieur très classique coup de pioche
une touche qui se termine par le premier
essai du match
l'ambiance est créé la france va gagner
facilement
oui mais voilà sur le terrain il y a non
seulement quinze gallois qui jouent
contre les français mais également un
arbitre un arbitre qui voit toutes les
fautes françaises mais qui est
curieusement myope lorsqu'il s'agit des
fautes galloise
quoi qu'il en soit les gallois n'ont pas
besoin de larbitre pour marquer leur
premier essai parfaitement plaît il est
en tout point identique à celui qu'ont
réussi les français au début du match 2e
mi temps
voilà le moment qu'a choisi larbitre
pour provoquer la colère des 40000
spectateurs de colombes après une course
de 40 mètres bouquet pas s'abonner phase
qui va la paix entre les deux peuples
c'était magnifique pour tout le monde
sauf pour les arbitres l'essai est
refusé
un joueur français était hors jeu en
revanche sur cette attaque galloise
l'arbitré ne voit rien du tout en dépit
d'un en avant flagrant
résultat un essai pour le pays de galles
qui lui n'est pas refuser les français
dominent et pourtant les gallois mène
par 6 à 3
on se demande alors si la france ne va
pas perdre le match et la première place
du tournoi des six nations par surcroît
bien que paralysé par la crainte d'être
sanctionnés par l'arbitré
les français monopolisent le ballon et
joue presque constamment dans le camp
gallois
cette ténacité fini par être récompensés
et par un juste retour des choses c'est
boniface numéro 13 qui donne la victoire
la france en marcquois deuxième essai
transformé par banier 8,6 l'habite
[Musique]